สวัสดีค่ะครูนิคสวัสดีครับครูหญิงสวัสดี
นักเรียนทุกคนด้วยนะครับสวัสดีค่ะนัก
เรียนเดี๋ยวเรามาเขียนวันที่กันนะ
โอเคคู่นี้วันนี้วันอะไรคะวันนี้ครับวัน
ที่อเมริกานะวันศุกร์
วันนี้วันศุกร์
วันที่เท่าไหร่ค่ะวันที่ 4 ครับเดือนอะไร
คะเดือนพฤศจิกายน
ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
ปีพ.ศ
อะไรคะ
ตอนนี้นี้ที่อเมริกากี่โมงแล้วคะตอนนี้นะ
ครับเมืองที่คุณนิดอยู่เนี่ยเวลา
19:35 น
เอาไอ้ที่ไฟเนี่ยอยู่ตรงที่เวลาพอดีแล้ว
มันเป็นวง
แล้วแบบกี่โมง
หรือเปล่า
ที่ไทยเนี่ยนะคะของครูนิคเนี่ยเป็นวัน
ศุกร์นะคะที่ไทย
วันเสาร์แล้วค่ะวันเสาร์ที่ 5 เป็นเช้า
วันเสาร์ตอนนี้ก็ 7 โมง 35 แล้ว
ค่ะตอนนี้ที่ไทยเนี่ยเริ่มมีลมหนาวแล้วนะ
คะ
ก็อากาศแต่ช่วงนี้ก็เป็นหน้าหนาวแล้วใช่
ไหมครับที่ไทยใช่ค่ะก็หน้าหนาวแล้วแล้วก็
เวลาเปิดหน้าต่างมันก็มีลมเข้ามาเวลาลม
เข้ามาก็แบบหนาวแล้วตอนนี้ที่บ้านครูหญิง
เนี่ยนะคะ 24
เซลเซียส
[เพลง]
ที่กรุงเทพฯเนี่ยค่ะที่กรุงเทพฯตอนนี้
อยู่แถวไหนครับ
แถวสะพานควายจตุจักรนักเรียนอาจจะรู้จัก
จตุจักรใกล้ๆจตุจักร
คนไทยมีความสุขเลยค่ะ
ก็มีความสุขใช่เมื่อก่อนน่ะคุณนี้ก็ไปแถว
สะพานควายบ่อยค่ะคือจริงๆแล้วบ้านคุณนิค
เนี่ยอยู่บางแค
มันใกล้กันเหรอคะครูนิคไม่ใกล้ครับถ้า
นั่งรถไฟฟ้านั่งคืออยู่ไกลกันเลยถ้านั่ง
รถไฟฟ้าเนี่ยประมาณ 1 ชั่วโมง
แล้วตอนที่ครูนิคมาเมื่อก่อนนั่งรถไฟฟ้า
เหรอคะใช่ครับก็นั่งรถไฟฟ้าไปคือจริงๆ
แล้วเนี่ยที่ไปสะพานควายเพราะว่าเพื่อน
คุณนี้เขาอยู่แถวๆนั้นตรงซอยปฏิพัทธ์นั่น
แหละค่ะบ้านครูหญิงจริงๆเราอยู่คอนโดใกล้
ๆกันหรือเปล่าคือเพื่อนคุณนิคเนี่ยเขาจะ
อยู่ปฏิพัทธ์ 23
โอเคๆไม่ใช่แต่ใกล้ๆกันแหละค่ะว่าไปวัด
ไม่ได้ยาวมาก
คือที่คุณนิคชอบไปที่นั่นเพราะว่าแต่ก็ไป
หาเพื่อนแล้วก็ไปเล่นเกมเหมือนเพื่อนจะมี
เกม playstation ก็จะเป็นเล่นเกมที่
เพื่อนแล้วก็ของกินเยอะเออใช่คือตรงเวลา
กลางคืนน่ะก็ยังมีร้านอาหารขายอยู่นะคะ
แบบโอ้โหเดินเลยค่ะมีร้านๆๆ
คือเปลี่ยนได้ทุกวันนะคะครูนิคผู้หญิงคิด
ว่า 1 เดือนนะ 1 เดือนเนี่ย 30 วันถ้า
อยู่แถวๆสะพานควายเนี่ยไม่คิดว่ากินอาหาร
ไม่ซ้ำกันเลยวันนี้ก๋วยเตี๋ยวหมูพรุ่งนี้
ข้าวผัดคือมีอาหารให้กินแบบเยอะมาก
ก็คือใช่ครับมีอาหารเยอะแต่ว่าของคุณนิด
เนี่ยคุณนิคจะถึงมีอาหารเยอะแต่คุณนิดก็
จะกินร้านเดียวอ้าวร้านอื่นไม่อร่อยเหรอ
คะจริงๆร้านอื่นก็คิดว่าอร่อยนะแต่คือคุณ
นี้คิดว่าเออก็กินร้านนี้แล้วแล้วก็ชอบ
แล้วก็เลย
ขี้เกียจขี้เกียจไปลองร้านอื่นใช่ว่าเห็น
แล้วมันดูอร่อยแต่มันก็เออไม่เป็นไรกิน
อันนี้แหละ
อะไรคะที่ครูนิคเนี่ยกินได้ทุกวัน
คุณนิคเนี่ยจะชอบกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวก๋วยเตี๋ยว
เส้นนะแล้วก็จะชอบกินเย็นตา
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวชมพู
ไม่รู้ว่านักเรียนจะเคย
เพราะว่า
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่าถ้านักเรียนเคยมาประเทศไทย
เนี่ยนักเรียนก็จะรู้ว่าประเทศไทยมี
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวให้เลือกเยอะมากๆ
ก็อันนี้แหละครับคือเย็นตาโฟร์
ครูนิคชอบกินก๋วยเตี๋ยวเย็นตาโฟใช่
แถวนี้มีร้านอร่อยเหรอ
มีก็เนี่ยกำลังถามอยู่ว่ากำลังคิดว่าครู
หญิงอ่ะเคยไปกินไหมเพราะแถวๆปากซอยของ
คอนโดเพื่อนคุณนิคเนี่ยมันจะอยู่แถวๆมัน
จะมีเซเว่นใช่ไหมครับแล้วเดินเลยเซเว่นไป
นิดนึงอ่ะมันจะมีร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยว
ร้านก๋วยเตี๋ยวเย็นตาโฟอยู่ตรงข้าง
ใช่แล้วอร่อยเพราะเขาทำเย็นแบบเย็นตาโฟ
ต้มยำค่ะ
เย็นตาโฟต้มยำเนี่ยมันไม่เหมือนกับ
เย็นตาโฟปกติที่ครูนิคให้ดูหรอคือมัน
เหมือนกันไหมคุณนิคเนี่ยคิดว่าที่ไม่
เหมือนกันเพราะว่าเขาใส่พริกแล้วก็มีถั่ว
แล้วก็มะนาวบีบมะนาวไปให้มันมีรสชาติเผ็ด
ๆ
ก็เหมือนเอาเหมือนเอาต้มยำที่เป็น
ก๋วยเตี๋ยวปกติก๋วยเตี๋ยวต้มยำแต่เอาอัน
นี้ไปใส่ในเย็นตาโฟ
[เพลง]
ผู้หญิงเนี่ยมันยังไม่เคยกินเลยนะคะก็ที่
คุณนิดชอบเพราะว่าคือจริงๆเนี่ยร้านเขาคน
เยอะนะก็คือมีคนแล้วเขาจะช้านิดนึงซึ่ง
เพราะว่าเขาอ่ะจะปรุงเองทุกชาม
ให้คือมันจะเหมือนกับว่าเขาเนี่ยไม่ได้
ใส่เครื่องปรุงทิ้งเอาไว้นะคือเขาจะถาม
ทุกคนว่าโอเคเอาเผ็ดแค่ไหนเขาก็จะใส่
เครื่องปรุงไม่เอาอะไรเอาหวานน้อยหวานมาก
เขาจะทำให้ทีละชามทีละชาม
มันก็เลยอาจจะช้านิดนึงแต่ชามของเราก็จะ
เป็นรถที่เราเนี่ยชอบ
ใช่
ทุกวันไม่เบื่อเหรอคะกินเหมือนเดิมเหมือน
เดิมเหมือนเดิมทุกวันไม่เบื่อครับเพราะ
ว่าก็มันอร่อยมันอร่อยก็กินได้ทุกวันทุก
วันใช่เพื่อนก็เพื่อนก็ถามเหมือนผู้หญิง
นะว่า
อะไรกินอีกแล้ว
ที่รักทำไมไม่กินคุณนิดก็เลยคิดว่าแบบก็
ร้านอื่นอย่างร้านอื่นมีขายข้าวหมูแดงคุณ
นี้กลับไม่ชอบข้าวหมูแดงคือคุณนิคเนี่ยจะ
ชอบกินของมันๆแล้วบางที่มันแห้ง
มันมีแต่เนื้อหมู
ใช่ก็เลยแบบไม่อ่ะแล้วคุณนิดก็คิดว่าก็
ร้านนี้เย็นตาโฟเนี่ยไม่ใช่เย็นตาโฟ
ธรรมดาด้วยนะเป็นเย็นตาโฟทะเล
ครับ
แล้วก็มีเหมือนเป็นปลาหมึกมีปลาหมึก
คิดว่าจริงๆแถวบ้านคุณนิดหรือที่อื่นก็มี
แต่มันไม่มีเย็นตาโฟทะเล
ก็มันก็เป็นเย็นตาโฟแบบที่คุณนิเปิดให้ดู
อันนี้มันแบบพิเศษไม่เหมือนที่อื่นพอมา
บ้านเพื่อนเพื่อนก็บอกนิคลองอันนี้ไหม
ร้านนี้ก็อร่อยนะร้านนี้ก็อร่อยคุณนิก็
ไม่เย็นตาโฟเท่านั้นใช่ๆเพราะเราก็ไปหา
เพื่อนแค่แบบอาทิตย์ละอาทิตย์ละ 2 ครั้ง 3
ครั้งก็บ่อยนะจริงๆแล้วใช่แล้วก็เพื่อนก็
คิดว่าหนีบ้านอยู่ตั้งบางแคมาถึง
สะพานควายเนี่ยมีร้านอาหารอร่อยเยอะแยะ
ให้เลือกทำไม
แล้วก็กินร้านนั้นตลอดตั้งแต่ไปที่คอนโด
เพื่อนเนี่ยก็
หลายปีนะก็คือน่าจะ 4-5 ปีแล้ว
มาตลอด
จะไม่บึง
ชอบทำอะไรเหมือนเดิมเหรอคะแบบ
[เพลง]
เหมือนกินอาหารเหมือนเดิมได้ไม่ได้รู้สึก
เบื่อ
หรือว่า
จริงๆถ้าเป็นของกินเนี่ย
ถ้ารู้ว่าที่นี่อร่อย
แล้วเราชอบก็จะกินแบบนั้น
แต่ถ้าเป็นของใช้
ของใช้เนี่ยของใช้ส่วนตัวพวก
แชมพูน้ำหอมหรือ
สบู่ที่เอาไว้ล้างตัวอันนั้นก็จะใช้แค่
2-3 เดือนแล้วก็เปลี่ยน
กลิ่นใหม่หรอคะเพราะว่าพวกน้ำหอมเวลาเรา
ฉีดเนี่ยมันจะมีกลิ่นใช่ไหมสบู่ก็มีกลิ่น
หรือว่าเปลี่ยนยี่ห้อ
เปลี่ยนยี่ห้อครับ
อย่างถ้าเมื่อก่อนใช้แชมพูอะไรคะ
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
[เพลง]
อังกฤษอันนี้ไม่ได้สมัยก่อน
แล้วครูหญิงเปิดให้ดูนะคะของนักเรียนก็
ที่อเมริกามีไหมคะคุณนิดไม่มีนะ
น่าจะเป็นยี่ห้อน่าจะเป็นแบรนด์ของคนไทย
หรือไม่ก็อาจจะญี่ปุ่นให้เต็มที่
ไม่รู้เห็นหรือยังนะคะนักเรียน
แฟซ่า
ใกล้ๆกันนะคะ
ขั้นตอนแลบลิ้นแล้วคนไทยก็แบบคิดว่าอะไร
ทำไมต้องแลบลิ้นแบบแฟนน่าจะพูดยังไงซะเออ
กาแฟซ่านั่นแหละง่ายๆ
ฟังจากเสียงแล้วก็เปลี่ยนเป็นเสียงคนไทย
เองนี่ไงคุณนิคเนี่ยเขาเปลี่ยนจากแชมพู
โดฟนะคะก็เป็นแชมพูแฟชั่นซึ่งแบบเก่ามาก
นะคะคุณแม่นะคะ
ที่เปลี่ยนทำไมเพราะว่าคุณก็ได้ยินมาเขา
บอกว่าถ้าเป็นของใช้ส่วนตัว
แชมพูสบู่
ใช่จริงๆน้ำหอมเนี่ยไม่เป็นไรแต่คือคุณนิ
แค่เปลี่ยนน้ำหอมเพราะคุณนิดเบื่อง่าย
ๆสมมุติ
พริกฉีดน้ำหอม
อะไรคะ
ถ้ามีที่ชอบเนี่ยจะเป็นน้ำหอมยี่ห้อเป็น
น้ำหอมของอังกฤษชื่อโจมาโลน
อ๋ออันนี้ที่ไทยก็ดังอยู่นะโจมาโลนก็ชอบ
ชอบอันนั้นแต่ก็จริงๆเนี่ยพอหมดก็จะซื้อ
แบรนด์ใหม่ซื้อยี่ห้อใหม่แต่ก็พอสัก 1 ปี
2 ปีก็กลับมาใช้โจมาโลนเหมือนเดิมเพราะ
ว่าถ้าคุณนิคเนี่ยฉีดโจมาโลนทุกวันทุกวัน
ทุกปี 1 ปี 2 ปีเวลาผู้หญิงเนี่ยนั่งรอ
ครูนิดนัดเจอกันใช่ไหมคะแล้วพอได้กลิ่น
อ่านิกมาแล้วยังไม่ทันมาเลยนะแต่ได้กลิ่น
น้ำหอมอันนี้แน่นอน
จริงๆคือ
เขาจะแบบกลิ่นนี้นิคแน่ๆ
คนนี้ก็เลยแบบไม่อันนี้น้ำหอมเนี่ยต้อง
เปลี่ยนเพื่อนจะได้ไม่ต้องคิดว่ากลิ่นนี้
นิค
ไม่ใช่นิคนิคยังไม่มาเพราะว่าอันนี้ไม่
ใช่น้ำหอมนิคพอคุณนิด
[เสียงหัวเราะ]
แชมพูหรือสบู่
คุณนี้เปลี่ยนเพราะว่าคุณนิดได้ยินมาเขา
บอกว่าถ้าใช้เหมือนเดิมนานๆ
ร่างกายเราเนี่ยมันจะรับสารเคมีเดิมๆแล้ว
มันไม่ดี
เพราะว่าแต่ละแบรนด์แต่ละยี่ห้อก็จะไม่
เหมือนกันเราก็จะเปลี่ยนเปลี่ยน
เพราะเหมือนเขาบอกว่าถ้าเปลี่ยนร่างกาย
เรามันจะงงมันจะแบบอ้าวทำไมเปลี่ยนแล้ว
เขาก็จะสร้างเหมือนกับเหมือนกับเขาเรียก
ว่าเป็นเขาเรียกว่าสร้างอะไรดี
เพราะจะเรียกว่าภูมิคุ้มกันมันไม่ใช่อัน
นั้นมันจะเวลาเราไม่สบายเรากินยาแต่อัน
นี้คือเหมือนกับร่างกายเราจะไม่รู้แล้วพอ
ร่างกายเราไม่ชินกับแชมพูอันเดิมมันก็
เหมือนกับจะสร้างอะไรไม่รู้แหละขึ้นมาให้
มันสู้กับสารเคมีอันนั้น
ก็คือเหมือนมันไม่รู้จักมันก็เหมือนร่าง
กายเราก็เหมือน Restart ใหม่ว่าอ้อฉันไม่
รู้จักแกนะออกไปเอาไปจากร่างกายฉันเดี๋ยว
นี้
[เพลง]
ก็เลยทำ
ผู้หญิงจะได้เปลี่ยนบ้างเพราะว่าผู้หญิง
เป็นคนที่ไม่เปลี่ยนอะไรเลย
ชอบไม่ว่าจะเป็นของกินของกินก็เหมือนครู
นิคถ้าแต่ว่าถ้าแถวบ้านเนี่ยนะคะคุณนิด
ถ้าใกล้ๆบ้านน่ะผู้หญิงก็เปลี่ยนอยู่นะ
เปลี่ยนเพราะว่ามันใกล้บ้านเราเนาะแต่ถ้า
สมมุติคุณหญิงต้องไปไกลๆสมมุติไป
เชียงใหม่อย่างนี้แล้วเรารู้ว่าร้านอาหาร
ร้านนี้มันอร่อยมากแต่เพื่อนบอกว่ามีอีก
ร้านนึงนะอร่อยเหมือนกันอันนี้ผู้หญิงจะ
ไม่ค่อยเปลี่ยนชอบร้านไหนจะกินร้านนั้น
เพราะว่าคิดว่าแบบไม่เอาอ่ะถ้าเราไป
เปลี่ยนไปร้านนู้นแล้วมันไม่อร่อยอ่ะแล้ว
เราไม่ได้มาเชียงใหม่ทุกวัน
ก็เลยจะแบบไม่ค่อยชอบเปลี่ยนยิ่งแล้วถ้า
ของใช้ยาสระผมสบู่คือคิดว่าถ้าชอบกลิ่น
ไหนคือส่วนใหญ่มันจะเป็นขี้กลิ่นไงก็จะ
ไม่เปลี่ยนไม่ค่อยเปลี่ยน
คุณนิคเนี่ยถ้าเป็นของใช้ส่วนตัวเนี่ยถ้า
มันมีกลิ่นคุณนี้กะจะไม่ครูนิคเนี่ยจะเอา
กลิ่นอะไรก็ได้ที่มันไม่หวาน
ไม่ใช่แบบถ้าวานิลลาไหมนักเรียนจะบอกวัน
นี้ลามันจะหวานมันจะรู้สึกแบบ
เคยมีครั้งนึงเพื่อนครูนิคเนี่ยเขาก็เขา
มารับคุณนิกที่บ้านเขาขับรถมา
พอคุณนิกเปิดประตูรถเข้าไปเพื่อนคุณนี้ก็
เหมือนมีที่แขวนน่ะเป็นเหมือนกับกลิ่น
วานิลลานี่แหละ
ปิดประตูเลย
ไม่นั่ง
งงไหมงง
เพราะเพื่อนน่ะรู้
แล้ว
ก็เลยเอาวนิลา
เพื่อนไม่อยากให้ครูนิคเนี่ยขึ้นรถเพื่อน
นะคะเพื่อนก็เลยแบบทำยังไงดีนะนิคเนี่ย
อะไรก็ได้แล้วก็คิดแล้วก็อ้านิคไม่ชอบ
กลิ่นวนิลาเอาอันนี้ลาใส่แต่มันก็แปลก
เพราะคุณเพราะคุณเล็กเนี่ยชอบก็คนนี้ก็
ชอบกินขนมหวานแต่ถ้ามันเป็นกลิ่นของหวาน
แบบ
กลิ่นวนิลาที่มาจากสบู่แชมพูเนี่ยไม่ชอบ
ก็บางครั้งมันอาจจะแบบกินใช่ไหมคะกิน
เนี่ยมันอร่อยเนาะแต่กลิ่นเนี่ยมันจะแบบ
ว่า
รู้สึกไม่ค่อยโอเค
มันแค่รู้สึกว่าเหมือนตัวเรามันไปโดนวัน
นี้ลาแล้วมันเหมือนเหนียวๆอ่ะ
เป็นคาราเมลอย่างนี้หรอ
ก็เลยชอบก็เลยเป็นคนที่แบบเออบางอย่างถ้า
เป็นอาหารเป็นของกินถ้าชอบร้านไหนก็จะไม่
ค่อยเปลี่ยนใช่ไหมคะแต่ถ้าเป็นของใช้ส่วน
ตัว
ของใช้ส่วนตัวยาสระผมสบู่ก็อันนี้ก็จะ
เปลี่ยนไปเรื่อยๆหรือว่าน้ำหอมเพราะว่า
ถ้าไม่เปลี่ยนเดี๋ยวเพื่อนจำได้
ก็เลยเอามาคุยให้ฟังนะคะแต่ว่าวีดีโอนี้
เนี่ยหมดเวลาแล้วเวลาแล้ว
เราเจอกันใหม่ในครั้งต่อไปได้ค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ